Olá a todos pessoal daqui quem fala é o D4rk
aviso rapido se escreve no canal do meu amigo kayky narheus secundario
eu hoje trago-vos aqui uma coisa que
que vocês  pedem a muito tempo, e eu prometi trazer também que é
jogos de terror!!!     (Hé)
jogo muito assustador que muita gente esta a jogar agora é tipo five nights at freddy's
mas não é o fredy atraz de nos não é uma vovozinha com um bastão na mão
eu confesso que só de ouvir 0 sobre este
jogo portanto se você tem alguma dica
para passar este gol vários níveis que o
jogo possa ter eu não sei como embaixo
ajuda e pode ser que eu traga mais
vídeos do guarani e outra coisa pela
cabeça é 30 e mostrar no digital cidade
do rock in rio eu vou lá fazer um show
em cima do palco juntamente com um pico
dentro por isso e por isso vai ser muito
divertido basicamente ou recriar um dos
vídeos que eu já vi aqui no canal em
palco pra vocês totalmente ao vivo só de
que vai ter co2 fusões e talvez não se
vendo mesmo assim ela prometeu
mas vamos lá grammy foi silencioso ela
ovo qualquer coisa é nossa vizinha é
mais um da nfp-e mente que se deixar
cair um objeto no chão isso produz um
som que ela vai ouvir a mesma então
temos que ter cuidado com o objeto e com
o barulho não vai fazer pressão do de 90
no interior cel frommer trepb atleta de
rio do sul ela tem 62 escolas eles
quando baixo da cama e dos 500 pois aqui
em baixo risco tem que ser que eu apenas
tenho cinco dias e tudo o que eu preciso
da casa estar calado está silencioso é
ouvir qualquer coisa é grande e isso é e
velho tema nunca boa sorte não vai jogar
só eu acho que já sei tudo é só não
fazer barulho eu vou conseguir jogar
stillborn olha aí falei peixe quarto
escuro para tudo isso está sendo minado
tem o pintor nesta casa é muito suja eu
já consegui controlar que o bonequinho
a um canto ou eu vou esconder debaixo da
cama porque já fiz munique que é e vai
abrir a porta eo portal oi isso é tudo
advogada velha do mario cravo é melhor
sair do meu quarto eu tenho medo de sua
gestão alega e eu mesmo quantos sozinho
mas em jogo é muito gato ok vamos ter
bastante calma
looooool nota ruim eu não vi de costas
não não
meu deus este curso já está assim
empolgante empolgante será que ela viu
meu deus meu coração tá tá tá assim
vamos sair da cana seu casario que a eu
baixo chances e isso assim não faz tanto
barulho vamos aproveitar esta função não
é nada deixa o nosso jogo em já vi uma
treta não deixo aqui para ganhar michel
eu não vou deixar apanhar ar frio nunca
seja apanhada pela armadilha do rio usou
duas têm duas porque essa aqui é a
primeira pelo inter b pra cair depois na
escada ainda é contra na cabeça eu havia
muito inteligente o início a tem uma
porta ou janela e um haitiano com um
futuro livre vou correr para o o o meu
deus já foi muito apertada aqui
o início é veneno que tem pt pode ser
infinito logo a não ok final tem preta
ok vamos esperar até ver embora eu já
estive muito intenso nos pra mim porque
agora vamos sentar com o o vamos tentar
procurar encontrar já a parte ofensiva
chegando tempo estou aqui vamos pegar
nem conheciam há um só tom está um
software é só mais um quarto bem podres
porque eles não faltam
meu deus
havia também muito nela estava lá também
como é que ela vai atrás de mim me
esconder basta caminho semelhante à que
estava claro claro que ela sabia né mas
acabou por acontecer isso
ok vamos lá de noite a este nível de sal
será o que já estava a tentar fazer o
jogo do próximo mandato instruções fora
do prazo
já sabes bem no início e possui câmera
kim collins agora e agora é melhor do
que é que vai fazer a e você ir
tranquila
entre abril ea porquinha acho que o
ataque caraças até aqui porque o porto
não abriu a porteira abriu
alguém fazer força do outro lado mesmo
tempo nilson
vamos lá pessoal vamos continuar o pato
em que qualquer coisa é um drop não
perde tempo e deixar que ele não sei não
sei nada sobre qualquer coisa que não
seja usado para abrir a porta aqui agora
já abriu ontem uma de venda total e
fechou a porta
ela vai subir calma calma calma as
condições dentro do cacifo cowell se ela
não conseguir ver ou será que eu tenho
que ficar parado porque ao longo de um
espaço mesmo dentro do cacife só
comentei tudo o que vocês acham que é
certamente você já sabe mais do que eu
as igrejas do jogo né então expliquei
nem tudo quem quer saber tudo tem que
matar velho quer fugir da casa onde eu
tenho que ir às compras tem 20
parlamentares ontem a leve impressão que
vai dar voz é ouvida por quem vai da
costa vai instalar a biblioteca de que
nós temos aqui também não jura a eu
posso usar isso de que preservaria a
beleza é porque eu não fiz nada cai de
quatro nós vamos conseguir avançar as
noites eu não percebo porque
supostamente devia repetir à noite
porque não consegue passar mas por algum
motivo
já cuidei consegue na cabeça e não levou
o hospital é melhor ela mesmo hospital o
outro cheio de sangue ela não quer saber
de mim armas continuam aqui a gente
pensa como sobrepor outra vez uma
banheira pedra lá para este jogo
a palavra portas à praça velha como
assim de 5 do sbt vai buscar com mais
calma vamos baixar aqui já neste
concelho outra mesmo já tendo essa
partida calma agora vou abrir a porta do
novo estádio já viu já viu já viu é
cabível é jorge ou não cuidar do espaço
aqui tem um cofre
e de moura ac um jogo o pessoal vamos
ganhar outra vez agora com muito mais
cuidado aqui e vamos tentar esconder
muito mais por eu ter acostumado aqui já
só soube controlar amigos são o meu
susto ou caiu já abrir a porta
primeiro porque vou tentar passar para
outro quarto assim muito rápido e tem
uma porta que aí eu tive aqui tem uma
escada é isso minha casa ou olha aí eu
tenho um boneco é que o dela treinar né
eb1 da mata às vítimas
eu queria
não acredito eu morrer assim já é em
toda ela foi apanhar fui eu próprio que
da casa e como não havia então ela ouviu
o que eu tentei abrir a porta e eu vou
já entrar aqui não de puxar não
pressionar o botão não é muito difícil
como oo o piso de uma casa e ganhou
eu faço um scanner aqui acho que é uma
peça polícia
eu nem consigo chegado a tal modo fácil
e eu nem consegui jogar como eu tenho
que andar de baixo tipo assim acho que é
assim que ela é lésbica
eu tenho que andar tanto assim só serve
hoje mesmo como tem muito o que vocês
acham que eu deveria fazer ou então não
conseguir este nunca tempo possível já
neste concelho na cabeça outra vez foca
está tudo tranqüilo aqui vamos com muita
calma o melhor já nasceu com tareq ahmed
de juros nem como vou tentar abrir a
porta já pra fugir mesmo se bem que acho
que preciso de uma chapa ou qualquer
coisa que nem porquê de ocupar outra vez
na boca é muito difícil só agora vou
tentar andar mais rápido em vez de andar
mais lento e tentar não fazer barulho e
pressionar mais rápido eu acho que vou
conseguir falhei e jogar assim por aí
james bond correndo pela casa está uma
armadilha dos campos pode dar a volta na
volta e olha só chega no profissional é
meu está muito difícil né não consegue
esconder que hoje tem uma gaveta tem
coisas procurarem começou agora sim
estamos a explorar o jogo agora se
esconde embaixo da cama 8% já que ela
vem aqui e agora pessoal eu não sei se
neste dias eu tenho que ficar a noite
toda vivo os tanques em cada de
encontrar uma solução para a porta expor
crimes embaixo
só quem está aqui porque sempre tem é
porque se for só sobreviverão fique
baixo daquela muito tempo e já a ge já
preciso mas acho que tenho hoje mesmo à
porta então vamos lá tentar sair daqui
com ela porque está fechada à chave como
assim a única idéia agora avozinha o que
vamos comer o que gosta da cama eu
sentir ela vai parcelar esconde esconde
que está tudo calmo por enquanto está
tudo calmo eu consegui aguentar muito
embora nesta noite
nesta última noite que cada ser humano
cair agora escrevo avançada 34 eu quero
chegar até o andar lá de cima
eu já ouvi agora ela só vem a porta foi
gente quando vai ficar na embaixada
alemã
eu acho que vai prosseguir rock se ela
precisa que no corredor é porque isso
funciona mesmo assim ela uma portaria
bater e depois vai apareceu e rosinha
teme tomar um chá ou sp no entorno
agora que a chapa subam seguida ela já
tinham taue e olha a cara de o título já
que busca uma calma calma calma calma
tu não viste agora é impossível não
conseguir achar que basta campanha
impossível
ok ela já saiu da equipe ao sair ela
voltou a não já tira com a outra vez só
que aí com muita calma agora avançar
outra vez vamos pra isso corta aqui de
cima
como agora tem que saltar como eu passo
por outro lado em possível saltar aqui
neste jogo eu passar aqui morro ou
derrota ou o disco gay que ir lá embaixo
é muito burro que absorva significa que
já não tiver mais oito muito suado estou
muito assustado já então se você tiver
algum conselho se quiser que eu volte a
jogar é que este breve como tem muito em
baixo
deixei muito laquê neste vídeo e não
esqueçam dia 30 eu estava no rock in rio
digital site a pressão lá e é isso ao
fim quem vai até a próxima